you were saying in your debut stream
that you love rpg making games yes
just the most old just wretched like old
ass pixelated so many of those when i
was doing live streams
like mad father dude i remember watching
all of that like pewdiepie no someone
played all of it and
what is this game just to explain to me
mad father or you know rpg make a game
yeah
yeah yeah so mad father is this one it's
created by is it created by japanese guy
yes i think
sen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's the
guy who uh also did uh
oh my god what was that misal that's it
yeah but basically mad father is all
about this girl
who has a crazy dad
okay he couldn't tell he's mad yeah and
basically like she's like lives in this
it's been so long since playing the game
but like i can't remember what happened
callie can you explain it because you
probably played at the moment yeah yeah
sure so there's this girl and she lives
in a mansion with her her mad dad and he
does
weird stuff in the basement and you know
that from the beginning um
but basically where is this going
it's a ride so basically her mother has
died um and the game starts off
by you get these flashbacks and you see
her life and and you realize that she's
kind of like alone in this mansion with
her
[ __ ] up dad and his mistress and uh
they're doing weird stuff in the
basement that isn't just
what you think is going on there's other
stuff happening too it gets pretty fun
yeah um and so she hears like screams
from the basement and turns out there's
a curse on the house
that's based on like like some some
[ __ ] with like her mother is
angry or something like that maybe
that's a spoiler maybe we should cut
that
it's too late i mean the game's like how
old is this it is a really old
game it's a really old game um so
basically yeah there's a curse in the
house
and all these all these like bodies
start coming to life
like reanimated corpses and whatever and
uh it's basically like your classic
rpg maker horror game it's got like jump
scares and puzzles and
story and um it's it's super fun and
super crazy
but there are also some scuff parts that
i just love about it it's just
classic old rpg maker game for example
um
when your mad dad is like chasing you
with his chainsaw whatever he comes
after you and it's the jump scare when
he gets you right
the image just zooms in so far and the
pixels
that's the scary part about it right how
many pixels make up dead it's not a high
number
that's that's the funniest part about
rpg like horror games though is that
like
every single one like no matter how
scary the jump scares might be
there's just something really campy
about it that you just can't help but
laugh at
yeah scared like pixels yeah right yeah
what was that one rpg maker game i think
it's like to the moon or something
oh to the moon that's a really sweet one
actually i already [ __ ] loved that
one i was crying like a baby watching
[ __ ] pewdiepie player when i was like
50.
oh it's so sad yeah i watched the story
joe
wow yeah i was about to say i was like
that is like a hundred percent story
yeah yeah i actually think i enjoy
game stories it's fine when he's
watching someone else i
really think i like game stories when i
watch someone else play it yeah
but when it's me playing it i'm like you
want that game play
man just that that straight game man
yeah
until it is done there's also the there
was a sequel to that as well yeah there
was there was yeah
yeah much much later yeah i actually
liked it more than the first
i believe really oh really yeah i liked
that there's like a twist that's really
good and the plot is just
it it hits some like uh relatable spots
as we say on the show
it's different it's movies
i remember i played that on my channel
when i was doing let's plays and like
it's
the music man the music just [ __ ]
yeah it's so good
and it's all done by one dude yeah crazy
to think about like
i mean like the entire game just like
music this guy who did the story the art
the everything was just all done by one
dude like he had help with like the
music like
composition yeah he wrote it all and
just got someone else to like do the
composition for it but
he did the story he did all the like the
programming and everything it's just
i love that stuff just like just like
one dude just making a whole freaking
game
right i mean corpse party as well was
made by like three people
yeah i wish i was that talented i know
it takes a lot of passion
so lazy or like touhou was made by one
dude
i don't know talent and all i know how i
and all i know
what to do is how to talk about anime
titties
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can't even put a pc together on my own
your pc was like literally that meme of
like unlock your brain
yeah exactly unlock your graphics card
but what if we use more than 10 of our
brain
so like what would you say then is your
favorite rpg maker game
gosh there are so many um let me name
off some ones that i really like i
really like uh wada nahara have you guys
played wad in the harbor oh
is that the guy mageka right yeah that's
right yeah yeah and then he made some
other really [ __ ] up game called gekko
castle
yeah that gave me some freaking
nightmares i tell you what um
i really like uh the crooked man series
do you guys ever play those
i play i haven't yeah i i think i i've
played almost every rpg horror game oh
seriously
i used to do like because i used to play
them like exclusively on my channel
because like because i got really
massive off the corpse oh yeah
right right so naturally i had to go
into the rpg maker stuff
well my the first one that i ever played
was eeb um i feel
because sydney loves these kind of like
rpg horror games as well so that's why i
know some of these
is probably like the most famous one
yeah and it's old
like super old and then i feel like a
lot of people also know witch's house
yeah
well it's like a classic like jump scare
one um i need to play that on stream
i feel like everyone would really enjoy
pocket mirror is also really good oh
yeah that's a good one too yeah i
recently played that
yeah i don't know i'm not like i should
get out the room leave youtube listen
okay all you have to do there there's
someone who translates a lot of rpg
maker games and i recommend of course
obviously you buy the games of course
yeah yeah but um for those that it is
impossible to do
the translated patches are available and
they're very easy to access in one spot
and they're really good too
yeah yeah they're really good
translations well done again like just
someone is just talented and has the
time to just be like oh yeah
five hour game where it's like
exclusively talking yeah i'm a finner
translator
yeah yeah exactly yeah shout out to the
translators again
for sure i got so into rpg maker games
though that it got to a point where
after i played all of them
i went on to the the rpg maker forums
and just started downloading people's
like projects that they were working on
and playing them
oh wow and that was something let me
tell you where any of them like
memorable i mean by how not great
i mean listen i don't know that makes me
sound like such a dick
being like why try when you're not good
just get good
just get good i mean like don't be [ __ ]
i got a laugh out of some of them and
getting a laugh hey
hey listen man that that serotonin
release for one laugh
okay good fine be proud of yourself for
that
listen man no i had i had some some fun
times
i remember some some real janky ones i
don't know if this was
someone's project but there's this super
like obscure ass one called what is like
desert nightmare or something
and that sounds like an indian i think i
got it off the forum
and it's like you're you're this chick
and you get out the car your car's
broken down and you're in a desert and
it's a horror story and i remember it
was so
freaking jank but i played it all the
way till the end three hours someone's
just project on the rpg maker game forum
so i got invested
it was shitty but i got invested man
yeah i remember that
it was something is is this a compliment
or not
dude whoever mate whoever made that game
good on you i know you're out there
somewhere you might see this you might
not but [ __ ] yeah
that might be a cali suit you never know
oh geez don't take it as an insult i
genuinely had a lot of fun with that
game like the next
the next red super chat you get is like
hi i'm the developer oh
[ __ ] listen man hold on wait maybe i'm
joking
i cannot imagine going on a forum
looking for shitty games
hey i was desperate man you get
desperate sometimes after you go if you
after you go through all that stuff and
you're like i want more i need my fix
right like a cup you're doing that and
then me just doing super hexagon for
like the millionth time trying to beat
the hardest level
have you seen super hexagon yeah of
course i [ __ ] love that game
what is that it's oh it's like a visual
crack
game it's hard yeah it's it's like
epilepsy of the game
yeah basically
it's on screen right now it's uh it's
very [ __ ] difficult but i love it
that's the rhythm it's like no not the
rhythm game but like it's like uh
how do you explain in games like that
[ __ ] seizures
survival scenario have you played that
game where you jumped the block
yeah yeah was it geometry dash geometry
dashboard
it's kind of like in the same kind of
like same kind of genre i'd say where
it's like
repeat the level over and over hundreds
of thousands of times i get it yeah
i remember the one the only one game i
remember i can't it was called like the
impossible game or something i don't
remember where you just like jumped
like that
someone in the chat is probably
screaming right now is a geometry dash i
just remember the music was so good i
know you i wanted to complete it just so
i can hear the track all the way to the
end how'd that go
yeah same uh i i completed one stage the
easiest stage
we're gonna we're gonna get a blue super
chat being like hi i'm the developer
i got it all wrong [ __ ] you